this is a small Lancashire town in a
desperate search
where no one wants to give up looking
tonight search teams in the dark and
Rain responded to a community call out
wading into the river close to where
Nicola Bully's phone was found they
pulled out what looked like a green
chair but police are appealing for any
new information calling now for this key
witness to come forward a woman seen
here pushing a pram Who police believe
was in the area when Nicola disappeared
on Friday morning
as the investigation continues Nicola
Bully's friends say it's too soon for
condolences that the police theory that
Nicola fell into the river is not one
they can as yet accept as far as we are
aware there is no evidence that she is
in that water and I mean the police have
been incredible with the resources that
they have thrown towards that River
this is not adding up
and it's not adding up on a huge huge
scale which makes you think well then
the has to still be hope because
we're missing something something is not
making sense
have established this a community search
Hub in the village Tennis Club
as well
where people can come take a map of the
local area and try and help I've known
Nicola for
um
over 20 years it's a distressing time
for the family
and uh
my husband and I we just felt that we
wanted to come and you know just come
and look
this is one route along the riverbank
here or yes yeah yeah Lee ward has never
met Nicola bully doesn't know her family
but he likes so many others has seen her
story and felt compelled to come I think
it's one of the things that you read it
on the news and that and he thought of
each up inside you know thinking what
they're going through
for Nicola Bully's friends and families
there are still far more questions than
answers right now the police
investigation has been extensive it's
covered 15 kilometers of rivers all the
way down to the sea but it's still here
the fields where Nicola was last seen
and where her phone and dog were found
that continue to draw people all with
the same question what happened that
morning
we sent footage from the scene to Peter
folding he's a forensic search and
rescue expert and believes police need
to intensify their efforts in the river
it needs a high frequency sonar run down
the river to say she's not there I mean
we can we can walk up and down river
banks all day long and look at and have
people on the ground but maybe them
resources could be focused in other
places here neighbors friends family
even strangers and not giving up hope
they will continue their search for a
mother who went for a walk and has not
come home
Katrina Vuitton Sky News Lancashire